hi everybody thanks for coming
just curious has anybody have you are
been to be on follows talk about
typesafe c++ bunch of people surf on the
theme kind of interesting that many
actually most of the c++ talks at this
conference have been one way or the
other concerned with type safety so
apparently there seems to be quite a big
deal for us C++ programmers and my talk
is no exception but what you will notice
is if you've been to be on foot talk
that it approaches the issue from a
different angle so there's quite
apparently a lot of different
perspectives on this and mine is just
one of them so that's a small disclaimer
in the beginning we contribution about
who I am
I'm a freelancer working on Berlin
Germany working on firmware development
for embedded systems and what I consider
to be my mission here is to combine or
to bring type safety to low level
development because I always found it
quite baffling that we work very close
to the hardware and just write our
programs in a very imperative style
without taking a lot of care to make
sure that the commands that we sent
directly to hardware we don't don't take
a lot of steps to actually make sure
that they are correct and type safety
has a lot of potential to making sure
that things that we sent to Hardware
actually a consistent makes sense and
are ultimately do the correct thing so
combining these things is really what I
focus on what a kind of research and you
so to speak I have a couple of side
projects and these are the topic of my
talk which is about game console
emulation if you ever try to play a Sony
PSP in Nintendo GameCube we a Nintendo
3ds game on your computer for instance
you will probably have seen one of those
icons and these are projects that I
contributed to on a small scale as well
as on the large scale so been doing that
for about five to eight years depending
on how you count it so it's really a lot
of interesting stuff to learn about that
and if you're looking for an interesting
side project to learn about
peuta architecture for instance
definitely recommend checking out the
emulation scene I regularly post on this
stuff on Twitter my projects are all
public and I have a website with a blog
so if you want to learn more feel free
to check those out as well wait what is
this about surprisingly perhaps it's
about serialization and emulation it's
actually about type safety but they are
linked together as we will see in a
minute but serialization turns out to be
quite a significant problem emulate
emulation I will show you a couple of
examples about where it shows up what
kind of issues we have with their new
naive approach and one specific example
will be the inter process communication
subsystem of the Nintendo 3ds again we
will see what kind of issues arise what
do we actually want to address and how
do we air it I said and specifically our
tool of choice here well in generative
and declar would refer to approaches I
found quite useful in this case and tool
of use for this is modern C++ one of the
plus plus will help us reduce a lot of
boilerplate in our code we want to
mostly automate all of the annoying
things like keeping count of offsets
making sure that our types match the
actual data that we see you realize and
other things like that and doing all of
this automation we do not want to forget
that all the inputs that we have need to
be validated properly so inputs that are
supposed to be positive should not be
negative obviously otherwise it's in
horrible strings that should not be
empty it should not be empty obviously
we all need to check for that and it's
easy when automating things to just say
yeah ok we automate this and well then
we just don't validate our inputs but we
want all of it we want to have our cake
and eat it and finally we want to
maximize reuse throughout this entire
discussion there's bad last third of my
talk and we will see how that can be
achieved as a small note about what more
than C++ actually means here and we're
talking about C++ 11 with some C++ 17
features that said
work it does work that's sad
all of the things I will show you can
technically be implemented with older
C++ standards like C++ 98 the difference
is the implementation will actually fit
on the slides and for those of you who
might not have too much C++ experience
you will actually understand what I'm
talking about
where is a C++ 98 solution you probably
wouldn't understand it because it would
you know fill a book or something right
speaking of that small digression in the
beginning once you get a little bit of
an idea of where my audience is actually
standing at so can everybody raise their
hands when they work with C++ or at
least regularly use it and side projects
for instance that's quite a few hands
and quite a few non hands as well of
those of you who use C++ do you use
modern C++ C++ 11 or beyond so that's
almost the same group interesting and
finally how many of you do work on
low-level software like compilers
kernels frameworks or anything close to
the hardware really so that's
significantly fewer has interesting if
you're in one of the groups you never
erase their hand at all now don't worry
hopefully the code on the slides will be
clear enough that you'll be able to take
away at least the core statements and
the core ideas of what I'm talking about
if you're in the group led work that
doesn't use C++ 11 don't despair either
consider this more of a - of modern C++
features then if you've never worked
with low-level software well this is a
good opportunity to get to know what
kind of problems were tackling here wait
that's that that's all my questions for
you and now it's your turn if at any
point you have a question feel free to
interrupt me if I'm not seeing you just
shout at me yell at me whatever I'm
happy with that and yeah I feel like I
think a question does contribute to the
talk so even if you just want to clarify
have some super stressed feature clever
fired I do not hesitate to ask right so
let's dive right in emulation and
serialization
to give you an idea of why that's a big
deal I gave you a small overview here
about what the typical high level
software piece looks like I left left
side here we have two CPU side modules
where it's for instance communicating
with some sort of hardware and with an
operating system rather abstract how
does it look like in a game for instance
we might have a main application thread
right here
which is responsible for rendering
things or for doing the physics
calculations things like that as well as
a scripting engine on the bottom left
here and both of these might be
interacting with the host GPU and with
an operating system and how does it
actually look like when they try to
interaction before the main thread it's
trivial right you just have two
application threads and how does one
interact with the other well they just
call a C++ function and passing some
arguments and that gets the job done
they want you to do a system call for
instance to read a file you have a
similar kind of things you have a C
interface and you just call a function
and it's slightly more involved because
you need to make sure that your
arguments are parsing in the right way
because the kernel expects it to be in
some certain order but that also has
hidden away from you mostly so it's a
thing of calling conventions and the
compiler just decorates system calls
with the right calling convention and
just takes care of it for you the only
kind of non-trivial thing to do for the
programmer is when they want to interact
with the GPU driver for instance and in
that case I kind of just copy memory
around they copy some vertex data or
command buffer data into a cube you
drive a visible memory cheong again
that's all there is to it so it's not a
function call but it's a relatively
simple now let's look at it how it looks
like from an emulators perspective that
emulates a given game so all of the
modules that we had previously now
become virtualized so we have a
virtualized CPU communicating with a
virtualized GPU so say this one wanted
to just kick off some rendering commands
but we don't really know anything about
that what we see is just the virtual
CPU writing to this large pool in the
middle here which is main memory so just
what since some you know you eight
32-bit writes for instance two main
memory and we don't know anything about
that data until it actually triggers
some sort of operation so that's why I
like to call this chunk of main memory
the untyped C of raw data because it's
really just a big bunch of bits and
bytes and we don't know any of their
meaning until well they are already
being used for something and when that
happens what we need to do on the
emulator side is we need to deserialize
this data so we need to take the ones
and zeros and somehow reintroduce the
type structure on top of it just make
sense of it for instance if we have a
vertex buffer we need to turn all of the
raw you of the raw you a data into a
floating-point formats for instance so
it's possibly deserialization in a more
broader sense but certainly still do
serialization and similarly the
operating system when doing system
courts needs to turn CPU registers into
well-formed arguments because the viewer
justice are just 32-bit values some of
them might be just that might be a
32-bit size but some of them might be
might need to be grouped together to
form a 64-bit value for instance so that
kind of stuff needs to be taken care of
this is really really a quite a big
eaters problem and emulation so there
are a couple of a couple of examples are
listed here and the common theme is we
want to take this on type data and turn
it into some sort of high-level c++ c++
element so to speak and the first
example is the system calls where we
take Sapir edge' stirrers and forward
them to a C++ function another example
might be inter process communication as
we will see later which turns main
memory enter a C++ function call or we
might have some sort of emulated file IO
where we read something from disk and we
want to turn it into well a BMP header
for instance we knows this
kind of Astana pro-soviet we file
everything is a standard problem that
you see in many cases emulation has the
interesting twist that often we need to
do endianness wrapping on our inputs
because the emulated platform might be
big and eland like for the Nintendo Wii
for instance whereas those tend to be
little endian unless you actually
emulate on the Wii which is an
interesting problem because yeah right
and finally the GPU commander for
example I showed in a previous slide
yeah and a question that I want to
address in this talk is given that this
is such a ubiquitous problem and we want
to do it reliably and with our
boilerplate how can we do this reliably
so without boilerplate because
boilerplate causes issues because some
point will keep track of offsets we are
bound to mess up eventually we want to
validate inputs consistently and we want
to again as mentioned before and we
would want to detect invalid system
States what I mean with that
specifically is if we have a kernel
object file handle and that is used for
file reading operation we can't probably
be quite certain that it's going to be a
file handle just because it's used for
file operations but now if the
application uses this file handle two
seconds later for a synchronization
operation as a mutex then clearly
something must be wrong because file is
not a mutex so there's gonna be multiple
things really it could be a severe
emulation bug some arithmetic was
returning the wrong result so
accidentally the handle wasn't
incremented properly or maybe I don't
know some of our emulated kernel was
over writing data and just accidentally
whatever and the thing really key thing
here is that an emulation we don't have
a lot of debugging devices so we want to
detect these kind of states as early as
possible at all because we want really
to take all the debugging devices we can
possibly have right and today's goal is
we're going to address all of these
issues for one specific example and we
want to let the compiler do it because
they will have all the information they
need and for safe as a lot of
development and debugging time
an example of this just to give you a
quick concrete example is something I
presented that C++ London back in
February and this is the system called
example alluded at before on arm 32
specifically which is the architecture
used under Nintendo 3ds
the way this works is that there are a
couple of system calls about 100 of them
and for instance this is a DMA operation
DMA is just a fancy way of copying
memory around basically using dedicated
hardware but ultimately just copying
memory around and the application will
prepare some sort of parameter values
into the virtualized CPU registers and
then it will call an SVC instruction SPC
is just the thing that triggers a system
call it gets a number in this case 0x55
which determines which operation to do
so a DMA in this case and what we want
to do in an emulator is we want to
ultimately call some function called SVC
start email which implements all of the
DMA operations we somehow need to get
the values from over here into that
function call now it sounds like an easy
problem but there two twists to twist on
this first one is you don't just blindly
copy over the values but for some of
them you need to do special things and
specifically when kernel objects are
being referenced a lot I'll process hand
words or file handles you need to do
some sort of lookup process first so you
don't want to copy the voiceover
Bottomly but want to wrap them in a
lookup function so first twist that
would be manageable the more important
twist is that the parameter order so
yeah yeah the parameter order doesn't
actually match the register order so if
you look closely you will see that the
first argument here and b5 taken from
register one rather than register 0 then
goes on to register 2 which is that we
and then weirdly enough it jumps back to
register 0 only to jump back to register
for again so that's big fun and you can
imagine
that there were a hundred system calls
like these and all of them follow a
similar pattern but slightly different
register orders it's incredibly easy to
mess this kind of order up and that is
why we really want to automate this
process as far as possible right and if
you're interested I will put up the
sides after the talk and you can click
the link and follow it or you just look
it up on the internet whatever but yeah
um let's talk as I was saying before
we'll be concerned about the
interpersonal communication subsystem
instead and to do that I will first give
you a quick overview about the Nintendo
3ds and what it looks like
so it's Nintendo's current handheld
generation depending on how do you find
handle I suppose because then Nintendo's
which has come out since really released
back in 2011 so it has had quite the
lifespan for this kind of industry I
like to refer to it as a big embedded
system because it's comparable to
smartphones at the time of its release
boss to CPU cores clocked at about 300
megahertz it has a dedicated GPU which
is quite unique I'm not aware of any
other project products that actually
used to peak at around within the
Western market anyway and it has
relatively large amounts of ROM as well
so that was reflected in the software
stack it's not running a kind of custom
ish Linux kernel like your desktop PC or
laptop might be running but neither are
the games running on bare metal so there
was actually a kernel on the system a
micro kernel which provides
functionality for synchronization memory
management access restriction things
like that they are so that's really just
the bare minimum of a kernel so to speak
and all the interesting functionality
like GPU drivers audio playback or file
system access that is hidden behind
separate processes on UNIX system micro
services micro services so to speak so
if the game wants to do anything
interesting they always communicate with
these separate processors and that's how
anything interesting is done on the
system if you look at this as a kind of
stack we see at the very bottom we have
our Hardware the arm 11
CPUs and in the emulator what we do for
those as we just go through each
instruction one by one we have a block
of virtual CPU registers and we just
call it a C++ function corresponding to
the functionality of the current
instruction then move on to the next
instruction so you wanted to add two
registers together we just read them
from where a register Bourg add them
together store the result again in the
register block and move on that's at
least the simple idea if you want to be
fancy it gets more complicated but this
model suffice as for talked have every
top you have the game or the browser if
you fancy using that on the videos which
just runs on the emulated CPU we just
law the games binary and through our
emulated CPU on it and it just magically
does its thing so that's great
what's interesting is that every now and
then scheme will call some sort of
system call so we get a additional layer
in the system which is the coronal now
we could do a similar thing for like for
the game where we just run the kernels
image directly on the emulated CPU but
the system called interface is actually
well-defined enough that we can just
high level emulators is what we call it
so we just for each system call have a
C++ function that we implement that
functionality directly and in between we
have the services again we could just
load their own images and they would be
relatively light way to implement to
emulate but we can just implement their
their interfaces directly as well so
that's easy enough as well so the
interface between the game and the
kernel is what I presented at C++ London
and the interface between the game and
the services which is actually more
interesting this is what I'm presenting
today so hopefully that spikes their
interest a little weight and it's a
process communication what does it look
like well first of all why is it crucial
as I've been mentioning before to do
anything interesting on the system you
need inter process communication because
the interesting functionality is
provided in different processes so
there's one process dedicated to
rendering graphics it's called GSP one
for audio there's a different name one
for Wi-Fi one for connecting to social
media
something for accessing file system
whether it's for loading assets or for
saving a game's progress and overall
there are 40 different processes like
this on the system each of which are
serving different kinds of functionality
the protocol they use for communicating
here is kind of client-server
architecture so the game being the
client and the services being servers
seems reasonable and when they want to
communicate they do so using a request
response protocol so the game will craft
some sort of memory block in which it
has a kind of command header and a
couple of parameters so a couple of
arguments and we send that off to the
server to the services which then they
with their functionality and once that's
done they craft a response block and
send that back to the application these
communication is not done directly but
it's marshaled through the kernel in
case any sensitive data needs to be
sanitized or have any memory pointers
for instance need to be translated
across address spaces things like that
and yeah there is some sort of hierarchy
as well which is kind of side detail so
there are two classes of processes of
microservices high level ones and low
level ones and the game only has access
to the high level ones whereas the lower
level ones are concerned with things
like power management or direct hardware
access which you kind of want to isolate
from the game for security purposes so
it's quite interesting how that how that
architecture is not only used for a
separation of concerns but also for
security and a sense wait so how does it
look and practice I'm sure you're eager
to actually see a computer a particular
example this is an example of a read
file operation triggered by an
application like a game or the browser
the common theme here is that at the top
so this has eight 32-bit values in here
in the command block and has a command
header at the top which gives us three
pieces of information that are encoded
in this 32 bit value the upper 16 bit
right here the SATA 2 tells us which
kind of operation to execute so
the part that tells us hey I want to
read a file as opposed to writing a file
closing a file or whatever the lower
eight bits here tell us how many
parameters to expect and specifically
how many regular value parameters to
expect which are these five ones down
here and then the eight bits in the
middle tell us how many extra parameters
follow that need some sort of special
translation process whatever that means
so we can see with five normal
parameters
- translation parameters that matches
the number of arguments that actually
follow in this block and to see how this
translation process looks like prepared
a little animation which hope for the
works now yeah so we can see this thing
is sent off to the kernel and the kernel
will then again going through the
parameters one by one and copy it to an
intermediate stage in boffo animations
plane to fast
copy to an intermediate staging buffer
var Bottomly and for these two it will
do some sort of translation process as
you see in a minute and once that is
done the kernel will hand the operation
off to the service which then does some
processing indicated by the small G R
here and then and then the process kind
of begins in Reverse again so the
service has done its processing has
gathered the results and Warcraft
another command block like this that
gives the well sends it to the kernel
the kernel does the translation process
again and then sends it back to the
application right and at the bottom here
you see that this Susan pointer and
there's it could be a buffer address for
instance this buffer address is
different on the right side here it's in
this case if you wanted to map a buffer
into the target process the Corona would
take care of that for you and this is
what a virtual memory address would be a
different warm wait um
so given this kind of oh yeah and to be
clear where our emulator comes into play
is this more spinning gear so to speak
so the subsystem we talked about today
only gets this translate
but fur and wants to do something with
it so the question is now how do we
implement the spinning gear well was
sown on the next slide there was common
dispatch kind of flow so we first look
at the the command ID given in the
command header and select some
high-level C++ function that we want to
use to implement this functionality in
this case we might have a function
called do read file taking something
like a 32-bit file descriptor a file
offset 64-bit a number of bytes to read
from the formal file at that offset and
a pointer to emulate a memory so it's
not it's not a proper pointer in C++
because it's emulated memory so it gets
its own type in our case my to its
operation and then we turn to results we
do this in C++ using what we call a
two-pole so it returns a result which is
usually 0 to indicate success and au and
32 that would give us for instance the
number of bytes never actually read from
the file
once we select this annular function we
haven't actually called it yet we still
need to make sure that we can actually
call it I need to figure out how so
first we do is we verify the command
today to make sure that for instance the
application isn't sending us this read
file command ID but doesn't actually
send any parameters because that would
be malformed we want to catch these kind
of cases in the spirit of input
validation so don't worry about this
expression to imagine it's just what it
is basically very simple arithmetic and
once that that seems legitimate we
passed the command buffer and go through
each of the elements one by one and well
do the DC realization process basically
the twist here is that for some of these
objects so the UN 32 here is just the UN
32 in the function that is being called
so we just take it but the next
parameter that we expect was a UN 64 so
we want to pass two values these two and
stitch them together to form a 64-bit
value from two 32
for use and similarly for the next one
and then for the final one we get that
get this kind of buffer descriptor so
you've seen there two entries before and
they also belong together to form a
single buffer AdWords don't worry about
the buffer descriptor too much just want
to highlight that it exists and they
kind of need to be considered as a
single entity and separately once we do
that we can finally invoke our C++
handler function with the properly
decoded arguments get the result and
then we need to write back the response
header to the command block so that's
kind of the reverse process again if we
so we have a command header again by the
different number of response arguments
first one would just be our success code
zero and the number of bytes worth which
would be 0 XD 0 0 half our case that's
question over there
but could you speak up a little yeah
yeah I messed up the slides on that one
so the remote from the odd right so the
remark has been that we take a 64-bit
value for the number of bytes read and
return a 32-bit value for the number of
bytes right or wrong Ackley so I was
responding that it might be a mess up on
my slides I'm not actually sure it is it
might as well just be an oddity of the
system as well because quite frankly
none of the files on the system are
large enough to around the use of 64-bit
integers so I'm not really sure what I
would use that alright thanks for the
question yeah now the question is this
is a relatively easy slide you know all
of the logic we need to do Fitz and five
points so to speak so you might say hey
there's not actually that bad well now
consider however there are 40 active
processes on the system and each of
these processes has about a 30 different
IPC commands in total so each of these
requires different manner glue so this
five step process you know these are
three lines of code but this blows up to
quite a significant amount of code if
you actually translated to C++ so do
that like about 1200 times and you spend
a lot of time doing that so it's a lot
of work specifically I would like to
highlight the file system servers which
isn't just 35 30 commands it's it's a
lot so each of the lines in this table
is an IPC command and there are a lot of
them and I imagined unit needed to
implement this kind of five step process
for each of those you certainly don't
want to do that if you can avoid can
Harbert so yeah it's a lot of work or is
it so that is where we want to enter a
technique I call generative
well not only I call it like that it's
quite the accepted inium in the
community and there are a couple of
building blocks to this so ultimately
what we want to do with a nice graphic
here is we have what we call type lists
which are quite a common metaprogramming
device and we want to run generators on
it which basically allow us to evaluate
a particular kind of expression on each
of the elements of a type lists for
instance the type list could be a list
of you know types in a command block and
the operation could be to decode the
operation the values from a command
block which might be precisely what we
do in it later
so using these generators we can turn
type lists which are purely a type
system entity and turn them into runtime
code to automate things basically now
the question is how do you actually get
type list well we can generate them
directly from our functions using
limited reflection capabilities in our
language so what that looks like
specifically this is so to speak the
vision that I want to prevent for the
rest of the talk now is we start at this
function I will éclairs Li and observe
hey this function actually has all the
information we need doesn't have the
command re but it does tell us it takes
a U and 32 au and 64 which needs to you
32 values another u 64 so that's another
two command block entries and this
writable buffer
sorry I renamed the type on the slide
but it's the same as before you know
takes this buffer descriptor and the
buffer address so again to command
buffer entries and it returns two values
and the response command blog so really
in terms of the command block we know
everything we need to know to to handle
the command properly just from the
signature itself now the function
signature itself is not something we can
do anything with we just call functions
usually but there's the thing called
function traits in C++ it's not a
standard library feature or anything but
we can implement it reasonably easy and
what this will do is it will turn this
function signature into to type lists
containing basically uh the input
parameters so you thirty tu 64 64 and
the writable buffer and the response
lists and if we get that we can actually
do regular template metaprogramming
don't worry or fear don't have any
experience with that by the way but we
can throw well-known techniques on this
and write our generators that do this
kind of runtime code generation later on
for us and once we have done that we can
combine it all together and what quite
frankly I find I still every time I give
this talk I find this quite amazing
basically this wasn't yeah this five
pros five-step process we all reduce it
to the single line of code it's just
entirely reusable for all all the
command handlers in our system so
instead of do read Phi we could put do
close file do Open File and all of the
all of the thing files together and they
are all handled by the single function
and it will just use all of the
necessary operations to be done from the
function signature so in terms of
automation this is as good as it gets
really
so yeah advantages it's all automated
there's no room for a possible typos or
mental arithmetic errors anymore
it's typesafe because decoded data
matches the subglottis function
signature by design there was no way we
could decode a UN 32 value for instance
and accidentally positive a 64 bit
parameter by implicit conversion for
instance because it will always take a
64-bit value if the parameter was 64 bit
and that's by design really which always
a good thing to say and a bonus it's
easier to read because well there's
nothing to read anymore it's just that
single line of code so anybody you're
looking at that code would have an easy
time understanding what it does right so
the next well the rest of the talk will
basically be concerned with how we
implement this so function trades if
you're not familiar with the term trades
it comes from the type trades that we
have which
give us information about a particular
type so we can ask C++ Hays it's this
type a pointer is it an integral in
Antigua value is it a floating point
things like that if you apply this
concept functions knows just what a
function trade is and specifically what
we're interested in is getting the
parameter list and the return type so in
other words we want a C++ structure
template structure taking the function
type it has two members these aren't
data members and members or anything
that they are types of their own so we
get one type def arguments which is just
a type list of the parameters of the
given functions so this might be our u
32 u 64 u 64 write up a buffer list from
before and similarly we get a result
type def in the function trade that
tells us what the return type of the
function is so that would be our result
and the number of bytes written but not
the actual virus but just the types
implementing this can be quite quite
cumbersome so that's why I recommend
using either of the two libraries listed
on the slide here at least one of them
actually has a standalone version as
well if you don't fancy be using boost
for any particular reason
for our case actually implementing them
will be really really easy because we
have a very specific kind of functions
mainly just free functions and you can
just implement it using this code I will
not go into detail about how it works
but I found it quite interesting to know
that such a powerful device actually can
be implemented in like what seven lines
of code or so as opposed to two hundred
lines of code and this actually works
perfectly fine for our purpose let's now
get us
now the core idea that we have is we
want to take the tablets we get from
function trades and want to turn them
into run taco well how do we do that
they are kind of to legislate proaches
to this one being recursion so you take
the front of a front type of the first
type of the type list execute the
operation on it then drop it off the
list and recurse mentally the tail of
the function so yeah in the tail of the
type list the other one might be to use
a arm old-style metaprogramming library
like boost MPL boost town but the new
approach is service big our parameter
pack expansions which are based on
variadic templates which are a lot of
very important words if you've never
heard about them we see that it in a
minute another one being a fault
expressions so these two features allow
you to do the same thing as recursion
and this for each thing and a very
concise and very intuitive manner as
well so that's quite a big venon to win
in terms of how modern c++ enriches the
style of programming that we use right
so this is what we like to do you know
how do we generate this code well to
clarify again get this kind of type list
which is just the arguments of our
function which we got from function
traits and we've had this kind of
command block that we want to read the
bodies from well let's start very small
let's suppose we had some sort of
primitive a decode entry function that
takes a given type and an offset so this
would be one two three you know just
counting into the command buffer and at
that offset in the buffer it will decode
a value of the hidden type so in this
case it will just get the UN 32 but in
this case it would actually pass to var
two entries from the command buffer and
stitch them together and then once that
is done it so this is taken very
reference so it will increment the
offset automatically for us so we can
just call the decode entry function
multiple times with different types to
step through the command buffer and to
get all the results
so I will show the implementation of
this function in the next slide but
assuming we already have it so we were
already habit what can we do we can now
write a function decode all which is a
very attic template function what that
means is it takes multiple types which
we indicate by these triple darts takes
any number of types that you want to
pass it to you as a regular function
parameter it just takes the command
block and the function implementation we
keep an offset parameter starting at one
which skips the command header so
starting at the first actual entry of
the e buffer and then we do this so
ignoring ignoring all the weird stuff
around this what we do is we just call
the decode entry function at the at the
type at the current type of current
offset at the command block now what we
do is we put three dots after this
expression and this is what we call a
parameter pack expansion and what this
will do is it will take this expression
and duplicate it for each of the
parameters that were passed to the
function template so if we give this
this type list this will expand to
something like decode entry u and 32 so
and so comma decode entry you in 64 so
and so comma and the same for the other
64-bit value and a veritable buffer now
that is not quite what we want yet but
it's the largest part of it no the only
thing we want to do is we will actually
want to apply the decoded arguments to a
function which is precisely precisely
our handler for the for the RPC command
it's do read file so do we define just
gets the decoded results directly
inserted into the function call so that
the arguments will just be there the
function call will stitch them together
and return the result from the handler
so this blend is this faded in a lot of
stuff but ultimately that's just all I
did there I just added the function call
and you need a new template argument
function argument it's really no big
deal wait
yep really very templates and parameter
packs awesome for this kind of thing
because you know I haven't shown you
this Dakota NP function yet but naively
might have expected that actually
iterating over the entire command block
might require some sort of for loops and
more advanced in necks counting or
anything but no really it's all boils
down to this parameter pack expansion at
the bottom right here so that's really
really powerful now if we actually want
you to see how decode entry is
implemented he could start on
specializing your function for each of
the different types that we might have
but there's actually in C++ 17 and
easier feature to do so and that's
called constant exper if so what context
brief does if you come visit confused
about it actually you get in all the
context prefer now and just pretend this
a sniff we have an if check that checks
using a type trade is same v whether T
is au and 32-bit value if it is then we
know okay we just return the value at
the current block block offset and post
increment the offset I just returned
that because the previous value from the
function so that's easy that is not the
case well would you other stuff now
let's say so that is really all we need
for 32-bit values say we had a 64-bit
value
well we won't hit this case but we might
have the next case for 64-bit values and
again it's really relatively easy we
just take the first value and the second
of all you increment the offset after
reading each and stitch them together
and return that again relatively easy
suppose we had a different one well if
it's a veritable buffer we just read the
descriptor we do some sort of more
advanced logic here because we need to
deep t care what the descriptor first
which I will not bore you with but it
might return you some sort of size for
instance and then you get the address
and construct a veritable
buffer object from the address and the
size in this case we just ignore all the
flags right now I told you to ignore
context brief for now well what the
context production makes sure that
there's not a UN 32 it just ignores
whatever is and
inside of here you need to do that and
if you to actually be able to rely on
the type being 32-bit so in this case
well what why you need to do that is
because these three branches have
different return types but you always
want to actually return the type of your
respective branch and that is always
determined by the type ass to the
function so really this is quite a
concise and neat way to specialize a
function easily you for different types
it's in c++ seventeen so requires
relatively modern compiler support but
if you can use it it's really really
nice what to get back to the full exam
bar here now that you've seen this again
we've already killed all and apply
function and just use a parameter pay
expansion to step through the entire
buffer blue red yellow green one by one
and gather results and call a function
handler for that now there two caveats
with this first one it well first of all
there's no water papers is always nice
but there two caveats the first one is
this is actually not a very early
template what we actually need is to
pass a single template parameter which
is just a tuple with the given type list
I won't go into details about how
they're how to solve that basically you
need to stand a problem really and just
a technical one you turn the function
into a function object which is a
structure that has a function call
operator and it gets complicated but
really it's a standard technique if you
run into this kind of issue and I won't
don't want to bore you with that the
more interesting caveat however is the
handler right here so we have a function
call with a given arguments and this is
a decode like the steps for the buffer
one by one incrementing the offset each
time so we really depend on this being
executed in sequence what you wouldn't
want the compiler to start evaluating
the decode entry of the writable buffer
thing first because at that point offset
is still one I would decode the wrong
thing the route so really we want to
enforce the compiler to start at you and
32 you but the issue is that in function
calls
expression or it is not well specified
and the C++ standard it's just left to
the implementation which auditive are
your things in that's something you need
to take care of and there are tricks to
get around it
initialize the list is a common keyword
and that aspect I don't want to go into
detail about how to resolve that
specifically because we're kind of
running short of time already but I just
wanted to highlight the issue so don't
throw between the copy of code please
before worrying about that issue right
time for a quick demo just so you see um
how this looks like in practice
and so you got to see a little bit more
code and maybe we can do weird stuff
with our desktop
again forgot to adapt the year the color
scheme for the presentation
unfortunately better hope you can still
read it as a font beginner for everybody
alright cool so that's not a lot to talk
about here really you can see similar
structures as we've seen before this is
just a dummy kind of environment with a
command block that is just a couple of
32-bit values and just by the play code
its third etc but here is the actual
function we've seen before to kill it
all and apply the slightly different
names I believe but oh well you can see
we're using the if Const extra cascade
here to DQ it single entry and then
again use a parameter P expansion to
decode the entire buffer and one go what
I'm using here is this call with
sequential evaluation trick which
basically constructs an object the sole
purpose of which is to call this
function f could be do read file in our
case with this essentially evaluated
arguments given on the right hand side
of the expression so that's quite a neat
trick I found to actually enforce this
order in constraint as you can see we
didn't really need to change a lot about
our code to make that work anyway now
suppose you wanted to call that we don't
have the function traits in place here
so we need to explicitly specify the
type list but we just do that call it on
a command block object and pass in a
handler which I creatively called teach
stuff in this case which just prints
hello world and prints the volleys that
was given see in this case it's the same
as do read for just with a single or
64-bit value parameter now if we
actually compile this
we want you to use C++ 17 and luckily it
actually compiles I didn't touch this
code since the last presentation but I
was still concerned it might not compile
for whatever reason and if we run that
we see yeah our handler just gets called
just fine it decodes these kind of
values just from the buffer which is
interesting because from looking at the
buffer you might have not have guessed
exactly how they kind of belong together
but our glue just magically takes care
of it which is nice right so that was
the kind of minigame one that I hadn't
had in mind what does my PC you doing
don't quite appreciate that right now
there we go
listy move quite quickly aside there's
still one thing I owe you which is the
encoding process for the response
parameter parameter block but ultimatum
that's the same kind of thing you have a
function called encode entry which for a
single type encodes the value to the
buffer and you have another function
called encode all which iterates over
the entire command buffer brother over
the intact response type lists and
creates a response buffer based on these
values now we can't use parameter PAC
expansion for that well I think study
not easily but we can use fold
expressions and these works similarly if
you haven't heard about them yet or
suggest you look them up because they're
really really powerful feature just like
parameter pack expansions just ready add
a twist that you can actually and
combine the values with a operator in
this case we use the comma operator in
C++ at the purpose of which somewhat
unknown but what it does is that it
takes the expression on the Left
evaluates a then moves off onto the
expression on the right in other words
it strictly runs the expressions from
left to right in sequence which
precisely what we want you won't we
encode from left to right that's kind of
an evil hack but at some point you just
get used to it I guess
ultimately it gets the job done and it's
a well-known pattern for those who have
seen it and if you want to use this in
production we'll just add a comment
about it and say hey fold-over comma and
the squiggly C realizes things and
that's just fine a small now we want to
put things together I promised you this
very convenient small one-liner you can
always see it's not that big we are we
basically want the template function
that takes the handler function and the
client log well at the beginning we do
they request error reading to make sure
that the the number of given parameters
actually match what's expected by the
function and then we use our function
Thwaites to get a request list and a
response list once we get that we can do
the verification logic I omitted that in
this case but can also just call the
decode all and apply function that I've
just shown you in the previous slides
you can see applying this is really
really easy actually the inflammation
was kind of verbose at some point but
calling is just the one line again and
then once we get the results back from
the command handler build some sort of
response header again this is omitted
but it's relatively easy and just boring
kind of and then we use the in call
encode all function to write the actual
results back to the command buffer right
so middle for now is the verification
and the build response header but this
is really the gist of it really all the
interesting stuff in one slide and again
it can be used for all the IPC commands
so we don't just need to call this with
D read file and I need to come up with
other logic for do open file but
actually we can really just do similar
one-liners for do open file do read file
and do closed file and all the others
right
so that this closes the chapter about
what I call reflective generators
because it's kind of combines the
concept of reflection with generators
and change them together to actually do
what we want
I found another approach quite
interesting and useful which is what I
call declarative generators
we're kind of running short of time but
I'm hoping I can give you
but what I mean with that ultimately
this boils down to a more explicit
approach of doing things right a more
explicit approach and the point is it
substitutes this kind of reflection
process in the first place so we get our
type list not from reflection anymore
but from what I call it a collaborative
interface and this is a more explicit
approach than what we've seen before
where we might have a namespace we've
put all of our file system related
commands in and we add new types
describing each IPC command on our
system so we might have one file type
called Open File which has this kind of
ABC command type but it encodes the
command ID right and the type itself but
that's not the only thing we care about
what we also care about us we care how
many regular value type based parameters
it takes so in this case it might take
some sort of flags file attributes and I
believe this is a file size or some a
path size or something anyway so it
takes a number of value-based types and
it takes some sort of a special types in
this case a static bathroom whatever
that means it's a platform specific
thing and my take maid respond with a
file descriptor of the opened fire to
the application so this is a very
different style than what we've seen
before but ultimately captures all of
the information we wanted again really
just on one single entity that can
operate on now we might do the same for
something I get fire size again we have
a different command with a different ID
different normal parameters different
special an empty special parameter list
and a different response list and you
can see how this might cascade into lots
of large groups of IPC commands worth
noting this is kind of similar to the
building at build up ladder pattern and
ORP were instead of having one big
constructor we have member functions
that kind of construct initialize each
member one by one and you chain the
function calls together like that
just that this is on the type system
level so it's all compile-time so to
speak kind of rushing through this right
now now the idea yeah how you define
would define these things as basically
you start with this template structure
and it gets just one parameter which is
the command ID it just encodes that
directly as a member so externally it's
visible again and then your open fire
function becomes this but well then you
want to add more well you can do the
same for CAD file size now you want to
add more information so what you do is
you add a nest obstruct don't do this
for any particular reason other than for
enabling this kind of syntax so this is
the member lookout operator so to speak
well that's the type lookup operator
just for in it for the sake of enabling
this kind of syntax we need to use
negative structs here so we had more
information by having a type list for
the normal parameters here and again
export them and the deepest scope well
if you want to add more information we
just nest another scrub and structure
and you can see where this is going you
basically just tag on more information
as you go along the way right and this
is a very different approach than
reflection we've seen before
but oh well you can similarly just oh
yeah and the point is basically you have
these type deaths and if you want to
access any particular property you just
take this type open file well and look
up the command ID value for instance in
it just get what you want you can see
that this is not too different in terms
of the generators though no generators
we get a slightly different signature we
now need to explicitly specify the IPC
request and we obviously don't use any
file and function traits anymore but we
can actually conveniently come verify
the request header because we can just
have some sort of request we can
basically statically build the request
header as part of the structure and then
we have a similar decode all and apply
function but now it's actually the same
decode all in apply function that I've
shown you before because you can just
again take the request list from this
kind of
death of the read file thing from before
again you just read the response simile
etcetera etcetera so ultimately the
generator part is not all that different
it's just the way we got the type lists
originally from and how we build the
command header right so at this point
you will be asking yourself okay what is
this actually good for and quickly wrap
this up well what is this good for we
can take this declarative interface and
we can write this glue handler function
again I've shown before
it's called differently but it's the
same thing you can use it like that just
like before but I can do entirely
different things now with this we're not
bound to actually handling things we can
actually synthesize IPC commands we can
go ahead and say I want to write some
testing code which needs to run on my
actual Nintendo 3ds so if I want to do
that I actually need to start building
command requests all of a sudden now and
have some sort of convenient reffered at
both cisco Mantello called the system
call that sense of IPC commands you know
you can see there's also quite a lot of
work to do and it needs to read the
response header and again turn into
something that my testing code can
actually handle in C++ code rather than
in each test having some sort of
decoding logic for the response again so
the synthesis can just be easily be done
we can just write a different generator
called craft block a craft block that
takes the declarative interface does all
of this logic for us and well in this
case I returned a command block kids
just would actually trigger the system
call and return the results similarly
you could have a logging bag and that
takes the well the logging bag on which
person are used for instance of my
kernel implementation where when I
encounter IPC commands I look at the
header and it have this very huge
database of declarative interfaces like
this go through all of them I find one
that actually matches so I can tell just
from these bits and bytes which don't
actually have this kind of information
paisay like only the actual
micro-service will know which command it
is but because the cone has this
database that actually also knows even
on the actual system it doesn't
point being in the corner can just
automatically log all of these commands
and their parameter lists rather than
just printing out the raw command block
and stitching this together manually so
those really really powerful and this is
really the the the core strength of this
declarative interpreter interface
approach it's reusable among many many
different contexts and you're not bound
to one specific purpose especially
because you can start gradually you can
hand you novel if you code for the
handler a lot then once you decide to
write a new kind of piece of
functionality well all you need to do is
write in your background new generator
sorry it's just a really nice separation
of concerns so to speak and that is
really the power of this declarative
approach and declarative style program
in general because of decouples logic
from structure or data from control for
whatever way you want to look at it
decouples things that allows you to
centrally define the structure of your
IPC commands and handle the actual
things you do with them separately yeah
you can look at the slide you know
there's flexibility consistency
separation and stuff like that cut some
drawbacks there's a redundancy you still
need to write your handler function now
so there's an overlap in terms of things
you define however I would like to
contrast this from from boilerplate I
would call it redundant but I wouldn't
call it boilerplate for the reason that
consistency is ensured so whatever you
do there was no room for typos it's more
work for you to type things out but who
typed them wrong the compiler will
complain about you because everything
needs to be consistent and it's checked
statically at compile time but yeah it's
not quite as automated as we would hope
it would be another corner is the
implementation complexity which is
slightly higher than in a reflection
thing you have no way to gorgeous right
now but if you see the implementation it
will be slightly more complex well
that's just your price you have to pay
for come for the flexibility but yeah
common to both approaches is
you have no boilerplate and it's type
safe and correct by design which is
really really nice and ultimately what
we were aiming for
what I meant to show a small mini duel
for this
well then quite have time for this but
basically in my project I really have
these separate header files where have
huge databases of these commands each
command gets its own declarative
interface that's also quite useful for
documentation purposes I meant to show
this off that I'm running out of time I
was meant to do a quick digression on
node and performance but the bottom line
is it's fast we're just doing compile
time operations on type lists so really
it's it's as efficient as if you had
written all killed by hand because
compiler writers would actually have to
go out of their way to generate code
that is less efficient than what you've
written so it's really confirmed of
reassuring that you can write these
things you can build powerful
abstractions and you know even in
resource constrained or timing critical
environment this will just work because
it just compiles to optimal assembling
way to conclude we've seen that how
untyped data makes civilization center
accumulation and various different
problems domains but also another
process communication specifically we've
seen how generators help us to get rid
of all of the spoiler curve the code and
automatically turn lists of types into
the runtime code that we actually want
in this case for expressions are quite
big for this and parameter vex
especially as well to reduce complexity
and just write complex expression really
concisely and to get typeless we have
two approaches the first one being
reflection which synthesizes the type
lists directly from function signals as
in our case I'm really hoping that C++
20 or 23 will get more extensive
reflection capabilities because then we
could start you know writing support for
structures on reflecting on them and do
really all kinds of useful things on
these so I'm really looking forward to
any progress on that area we've seen the
declarative interfaces which are an
eternity after that which allow
maximizing you reuse because you can
write very generic definitions but have
different generators for different
purposes weight and ultimately the
bottom line of all of this is you get a
vastly more maintainable and more
expressive solution that requires no
boiler had
and all of that basically zero
performance though ever had so hopefully
you'll be able to take some lessons away
from this that's all I have to say
really there any questions feel free to
come up to me later after the talk
because we I'm afraid we don't have any
time anymore so far thanks for your
attention
[Applause]